hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast an intersection of
cannabis and nutrition for the treatment
of cancer patients presented by Debra
Kim 'less medical director forward grow
I am Kaylee baka bobrucz and I will be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab routes
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having the
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located on the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
ken lens I will now turn the
presentation over to her Thank You
Kaylee and thank you to everyone at lab
roots for inviting me to speak on my two
favorite subject matters nutrition and
cannabis medicine so my journey into
nutrition and cannabis medicine started
off as sort of a thought question and
the question was what if prior to
beginning any medical treatment
including cannabis medicine what do we
first changed our internal milieu what
if we created an internal environment
that can actually be receptive to
healing and what if that process of
changing the body's internal environment
is not that difficult to do and all we
had to do
is change the foods that we eat food is
known to either create or destroy health
chronic diseases are directly linked to
poor eating habits I don't think that's
a surprise to anybody but what am I
talking about I'm talking about a whole
food plant only diet no processed foods
I'm intentionally not using the V word
vegan because coca-cola and Oreo cookies
and even some pop-tarts or vegan I'm
talking about real food found in nature
no animal products including no eggs no
dairy no fish no chicken nothing with a
face nothing that bleeds when you cut it
or comes from a mother and no processed
foods including no added oils though
what will that do by changing our diet
to eating only plants the body's
internal environment transforms and miss
transformation makes the body were
receptive to healing so why am I talking
about food on a cannabis webinar because
I want the listeners to fully understand
the why in the hell I treat patients
before I share my taste reports today I
have over 300 patients that I guy free
of charge interestingly though even
though I'm an anesthesiologist and pee
medicine doctor the majority of my
patients are cancer patients and many of
them have exhausted traditional
therapeutic modalities they were sent
home to get their affairs in order and
to live out the rest of their lives so
the condition for me to participate in
their health care is that they must
change their diet they must check their
ph every morning and then and only then
do we even consider cannabis medicine
and actually this diet change applies to
every patient I guide whether they have
cancer
or not so now we're gonna begin as to
the how and the why I do this
so in medical school we were taught that
our immune system functions better in an
alkaline environment than in an acid one
well to me that was a pretty big
statement but it was not followed up
with anything actionable how do we make
somebody's body environment of alkaline
pH we have no idea how to do that
but as an anesthesiologist in the
operating room if somebody's blood gas
came back with a low pH there are a lot
of different tricks that I could use to
change it however life as we know it is
not an operating room and those tricks
are just that it was only a temporary
fix so the purpose of changing our
body's pH is not to be a temporary
thanks but to be something permanent so
that our body is ready to snow that's
why I'm and a a whole food diet so that
our bodies have an opportunity to heal
so I looked into the literature to see
if I could support my thought experiment
with anything in the benchtop
so interestingly in 2012 in the journal
of environmental Public Health they
published a survey of the literature to
see what impact if any was the effects
of an alkaline diet on health and so
they looked at a bunch of different
benchmarks they looked at the effect of
an alkaline diet on back pain on growth
hormones on muscle on bone disease in
the role of pH on cell organs and
membranes so the survey looked at a
whole bunch of these benchmarks and the
outcomes that they found where that
increased fruits and vegetables in an
alkaline diet would improve a potassium
sodium ratio
I'm a benefit bone health ie reduce
osteopenia and osteoporosis reduce
muscle wasting as well as mitigate other
chronic diseases such as hypertension
and strokes by the way
you know the top killers of people in
the United States the result in
increasing growth hormone with an
alkaline diet may improve many outcomes
from cardiovascular health to memory and
cognition including Alzheimer's disease
an increase in intracellular magnesium
which is required for the function of
many enzyme systems and another added
benefit for an alkaline diet available
magnesium which is required to activate
vitamin D would result in numerous added
benefits in the vitamin D apocrine
exocrine systems alkalinity may result
in added benefit of some chemotherapy
agents that require a higher ph all this
sounds pretty interesting
so the study's conclusion which I find
very interesting after the survey is
after all of these health promoting
benefits the conclusion was it would be
prudent to consider an alkaline diet to
reduce morbidity and mortality of
chronic diseases that are plaguing our
aging population
I don't know I'm imagining that if a bug
did all of these things the language to
promote this trunk would be a lot
stronger than using the word consider so
how do we implement a change to create
this internal alkaline environment the
most effective method is to do it by
eating whole foods no animal products
and no processed prepackaged foods and
there continues to be a big disconnect
regarding this information so I found
this two weeks ago in a magazine called
the week and they published this little
blurb linking processed foods and cancer
they share just a statistic that says
that for every 10% increase in the
consumption of processed foods there's
an associated 12% increase in cancer
risk considering that most America
predominantly eat processed foods as
their daily food consumption this
statistic should be sending out
learnings from every media channel every
health care provider should be sharing
the statistic with their patients school
lunch program should be changed hospital
foods changed but no I haven't seen or
heard anything more than what was
written here in this non medical journal
so an additional support of pH and
immune function there was a study in
April 2001 in a journal of leukocyte
biology so they were looking at the
effects of extracellular ph on immune
cells and showed that clinical acidosis
is accompanied by immune deficiency
inflammation and impaired immune
function and all of these things are
directly linked to chronic diseases so
this is why I mandate that every patient
check their morning urine pH to see if
their pH is 7.0 or greater sweetspot 72
to 74 but if there's 7 or greater I'm
happy with it if their pH is not 7.0 or
greater then we've tried to figure out
what they ate the day before that
created this acid environment that
hinder their body's ability to support
its own immune system in fact I would
mandate a food diary where a patient
literally writes down everything they
ingest so we can go through food by food
to see what is being handled properly or
not properly since we're all in end of
one and everybody's different but wait
there's more so this is an interesting
study from 2005 Journal of Urology where
it was reported by his study from dean
ornish
and his group where they took prostate
cancer cell lines they played it in
petri dishes
then they took the blood of otherwise
healthy men who ate a standard American
diet and dripped that blood on top of
those cells growing in the petri dish
and what they saw was not surprising I
mean healthy men had normal or
reasonably functioning immune system so
we thought and that first column where
it says s ad minus nine percent shows
that the blood of a standard American
diet suppress cancer growth by about
nine percent and then what happened was
that they put these very same men on a
whole food plant only diet for a year
and then a year later they repeated the
experiment where they took those cancer
cell lines the prostate cancer cell
lines play did him in a petri dish took
the blood of these men dripped it on
those petri dishes and saw the second
column under vegan minus 70 percent it
shows a 70% reduction in cancer cell
growth from diet alone so not
chemotherapy not special radiation
therapy not surgery diet alone so then
we looked at this that or they looked at
the same type of study this time with
breast cancer cell lines three different
types and they looked at blood of women
from who ate a standard American diet
and then two weeks worth of a whole food
plant on the diet so the black columns
are the standard American diet blood and
then the hash mark columns are the vegan
blood or whole food blood that women who
ate only vegan food for two weeks and it
showed a statistically significant
difference in the reduction of breast
cancer cells in three separate breast
cancer cell lines in only two weeks now
slow
down breast cancer growth rate is
exciting but even more exciting is
creating clinical cell death in breast
cancer cells or something called
apoptosis so they took the same women
they did the same breast cancer cell
lines plated it out on the petri dishes
and again two weeks worth of a whole
food plant only diet they took the blood
of these women and then tested to see
the kill rate of these cells and again
the black hatch marks are the control
the women who were eating their standard
American diet and then they hatch marked
columns are the same women two weeks
after eating a whole food plant only
diet showed again a statistically
significant difference in cancer death
rate again two weeks only of a diet
change these are compelling studies
which I share with my patients to give
them an understanding as to why I
mandate a whole food plant only diet
especially if they have exhausted all
therapeutic traditional therapeutic
modalities but wait there's more our
body is made up of more microbes than
human cells known affectionately as our
microbiome the microbiome that lives in
our intestines is actually determined by
what it is fed so you know that old
adage you are what we what we eat well
that's true but not only is that true
they are what we eat so what does that
even mean so it means that when we eat
all whole food plant only no processed
foods no added oil no animals or animal
derivatives our body cultivates a
microbiome and that
allows for microbes that are beneficial
to grow and those beneficial microbes
actually secrete chemicals known as
short chain fatty-acids the short chain
fatty-acids help to maintain the
integrity of the intestinal cell
junctions known as tight junctions to
help prevent toxins from getting into
our system this is otherwise known as a
leaky gut and that prevents inflammation
and chronic illnesses these short chain
fatty-acids in and of themselves are
very anti-inflammatory when we eat a
standard American diet filled with
animal products processed junk food and
processed foods that are junk but we
think are good for us we actually
cultivate a microbiome that injures us
they actually secrete chemicals that
distort the intestinal cell junctions
leading to systemic exposure to toxins
and inflammation which then in turn
creates chronic illnesses they also
secrete chemicals that are
pro-inflammatory so we actually have the
power to alter the composition of our
microbiome
and the results of that microbiome so we
have the power to either help ourselves
or hurt ourselves so interesting over
the summer I found this article in JAMA
and it's entitled starch based
superfoods may protect against a variety
of diseases and basically this article
summarizes the important positive
aspects of short chain fatty acids in
our body
however the conclusion of this article
where is a little bit different than
mine their conclusion was we now have to
wait for a pharmaceutical company to
develop a pill that contains short chain
fatty acids that would
confirmed this type of anti-inflammatory
benefit my conclusion of course was
change the diet to a whole food plants
only so interestingly gut bacteria can
influence either positively or
negatively all of these disease
conditions from aids diabetes cancer
liver disease rheumatic disease which is
a term that really is a catch-all for
autoimmune illnesses inflammatory bowel
diseases chronic heart disease kidney
disease insomnia obesity and autism and
when I saw this list I couldn't help but
think that it looks surprisingly like
the same constellation of diseases and
conditions for which medical cannabis is
recommended in legal states throughout
our country and I thought this is the
induction between nutrition and cannabis
so this is why I Mandy a diet change for
all of my patients if patients are truly
desperate to heal and they literally
have exhausted all traditional medical
treatment options and they're sick and
they're dying and they've come to me an
anesthesiologist and not an oncologist
then clearly we have a serious problem
and I want to give the best possible
chance for successes and obviously in
life there's no panacea however with the
above data I think we can all agree that
it makes sense to at least try it to
implement a whole food plant only diet
make sure our pH is alkaline to give our
bodies a fighting chance to be receptive
so net now I'm going to get into the
cannabis part again it was another
thought experiment that led me to how I
treat these patients so first before I
get into it I want to do a shout out to
the endocannabinoid system we all
understand that the endocannabinoid
system governs almost every single
biologic system in our bodies the
purpose of it is to maintain homeostasis
pretty much from every biologic system
from thinking to pooping to everything
in between but the interesting part
about this is that our own
endocannabinoids our own chemicals that
our body makes is made on-demand used
locally broken down quickly and not
stored and I always thought about that a
lot actually that if our body has this
system that there's this delicate
balance where the chemicals that it
makes are only used locally and not
stored then why would we need chemicals
from a plant that are stored that are
used predominantly systemically and that
are not broken down rapidly it actually
almost sort of acts like a Depot in our
body why would we need a lot of it which
is how my next thought experiment came
to be which is we should be using a
micro dose and so a micro dose that term
micro dose is really a term of art it's
not ten to the minus six and so I kind
of want to go over what that means math
wise and I promise this is the only
mathematical part of this talk so if we
take a joint which weighs about a gram
or a thousand milligrams and let's say
for ease of maths sake we have a
cannabis cultivar that has 20% THC that
means 200 milligrams of that thousand
milligram dose is is THC and about 30 to
40 percent of
that if sort of literally goes up in
smoke that if you were to consume that
entire dosage form by itself by yourself
you get about 60 to 80 total milligrams
what I'm talking about microdose I'm
talking about less than one to two
milligrams and that's just of I'm not
talking just THC I'm talking of the
entire dose that I see just for patients
and in fact the dose that I suggest for
patients have Ovitz in their raw form
have of it's in it's heated form which
we'll go into in a second
but total dose is less than one to two
milligrams and so to substantiate this I
look to get into literature which is not
easy to find when it comes to cannabis
and in 2006 from legrest E&L they did a
very similar Petri test on cancer cell
lines sort of like the Petrie cell the
petri dish test on cancer cell lines
that we discussed we're using vegan
blood but instead of using vegan blood
they used 10 abyss fractions and they
looked at a bunch of different cancer
cell lines they plated them in petri
dishes and then they looked at different
cannabinoids and then a high THC strain
and then on high CBD rich strain and
then looked at the number or the amount
of each of these it would take to slow
down the growth of these cancer cells by
50%
also known as the ice and 50 and then
they reported the results in micromoles
which to me was not useful so if you
used abogados equation and did the
conversion into milligrams that
milligram dose actually closely
approximated my thoughts about the
microdose so I was substantiated and so
for the case studies I'm about to share
with you the patients
all were afforded the same type of
medicine they used a cannabis oil
extract a whole plant extract half of it
was in its acid form or raw form the
other half was in its heated or
chemically neutral form it was a ratio
of approximately 10 to one but then 10
to one THC a the CBD a and THD it is CBD
but the total dose was about one point
one seven milligrams of total
cannabinoid and it was administered
sublingually so now that we have an
understanding as to what and how I treat
patients I now want to discuss with you
a couple of case reports so the first is
prostate cancer and we're going to talk
about two different patients so the
first is a 72 year old man with a
history of recurrent prostate cancer he
was diagnosed in 2011 with a Gleason
score of 8 and the clinical state of
teaching B and his PSA was 7.2 he was
treated with hormone therapy and seating
plan and had 25 sessions of radiation
therapy his PSA level dropped to 0.3 and
you remain that way until about 2015
where's PSA started to rise to one point
out in August of 2016
his PSA bumped to seven point eight a
biopsy revealed recurred cancer the
prostate and thankfully can't cat scan
showed and bone scan showed no
metastases he began his first of three
Lupron injections after the first
injection a month later his PSA remained
at seven point eight he contacted me for
help we changed his diet we started him
on low-dose cannabis oil and then he was
continued on the second and third Lupron
injections and so I asked bench
regarding benchmarks for every patient
every patient is different for this
patient is benchmark
PS a so the dark blue column shows after
the first Lupron injection the PSA at
its 7.8 level a month later after the
Lupron injection and the sublingual
cannabis oil and the diet change the you
read shows where that was introduced
along with the blue which is the Lupron
injection and the PSA dropped almost by
half the third month he received his
third Lupron injection we continued the
diet and oil and his PSA went to 0.3
month for no more injections PSA down
2.3 held steady 1/5 same thing this was
a year ago his PSA still remains at a
level of point 1 to point 2 he continues
his oil and his diet next case an 81
year old
otherwise healthy man with a 1 year
history of metastatic prostate cancer
he was a hairdresser and started to
recognize some low back pain and thought
it was just from years of cutting hair
workup revealed metastatic prostate
cancer he was treated with seed implants
radiation therapy and Lupron injections
he had an escalating testosterone level
and he was on deck ready to have surgery
to remove his testicles the testosterone
generating organ so testosterone for
this gentleman was the his benchmark lab
test and so we changed his diet we
started her mind
sublingual oil five times a day and two
the first blue column shows a
testosterone of 1315 after two weeks his
testosterone level dropped by 500 points
the surgeon said that was amazing
however we're still going to need
surgery he asked could we please wait
another two weeks two weeks later his
testosterone
to what they would have assumed would
have been below surgical levels
and continues to hold so is this
surprising there are many many studies
that have shown without even a diet
chains but cannabis and prostate cancer
working together to create either a
slowing of growth or reduction of or an
increase in in self camp cancer kills
next cases brain cancer and I'll share
with you two patients so an otherwise
healthy 69 year old man woke up in the
emergency room after his first ever
seizure an MRI revealed a tumor and a
biopsy diagnosed in is Cleo blastoma his
chief complaints after discharge from
the hospital was extreme fatigue he was
unable to perform any activities of
daily living without assistance and he
was a really big man and his wife was a
small person couldn't feed himself he
couldn't shower couldn't dress without
helping had cognitive changes couldn't
speak clearly was a loss for words the
only medicine that they put him on was
tegretol for prevention of seizures and
this is his MRI pretreatment and so
before he had an opportunity to see a
doctor
he saw me we changed his diet and
started him on the microdose cannabis
oil in the first couple of days he was
able to feed himself dress and shower in
at the end of the week he's back on his
computer he was insurance Alice Manning
he was closing out his accounts because
this was his MRI he didn't know what to
expect for some reason somebody he
ordered another MRI it wasn't me but
that was the result
and this is the side-by-side comparison
and the radiology report read as follows
central cystic degeneration clearly
responding to radiation therapy except
at this point the only physician you saw
was me and he did not receive radiation
therapy just a diet change and the
microdose cannabis oil and nine months
later he continued to manage the tumor
in his head
unfortunately though he slipped in fell
in his head and on autopsy it did show
that his tumor was smaller yet second
patient a 78 year old male with a
diagnosis of anaplastic astrocytoma
grade 3 he was treated with timid arm
for six months after initial diagnosis
repeat MRI revealed a larger tumor since
chemotherapy was changed to low mustn
somebody introduced me to this patient
we started with diet change in canvas
oil two weeks after the initiation of a
new chemotherapeutic agent this was the
picture the tumor before the diet and
chemotherapy the new chemo therapeutic
agent and the new cannabis oil after six
weeks of combination low Muhsin and
cannabis oil treatment MRI revealed a
tumor size reduction there also during
this combination treatment these were
important improvement of sensorium
activity and speech so six weeks later
this is before and after so is this a
surprise there are many many studies
that have shown either CBD or THC or a
combination of whole plant cannabis
helping to treat brain tumors
lung cancer - ate a 58 year old female
who was a smoker who is diagnosed with
metastatic lung cancer in 2016 with
adenocarcinoma of the lung she underwent
surgery chemotherapy and radiation
treatment prior to her chemo and
radiation she saw me because she was
given less than 10% chance of survival
in three to five years we changed her
diet and start her on low-dose cannabis
oil therapy and for her she was the
person that kept me up at night
because I thought if she inhaled
cannabis that would almost act like a
topical and I thought that could
actually be a benefit in this case but
she did not want to smoke anything
because she didn't want to trigger
anything that that would have her return
to cigarette smoking so we continued on
this sole sublingual micro dose and the
benefits of this was that during the
cannabis oil she was able to endure
traditional chemotherapy and radiation
which was very aggressive she was able
to maintain weight by eating she didn't
have times where she was nauseated or
vomiting she was able to continue to do
work she was continued to do her
activities of daily living and she
socialized throughout her treatments
it's the point where her doctor was
asking her what she was doing because
she looked better than the people that
was treating her and she's continuing to
live this has been over a year and a
half now with no recurrence of her
cancer and again there are lots of
studies that have linked at least
symptomatic relief of chemotherapy Wow
with cannabis oil and so now to me the
unsung hero of cannabis treatment are
topicals and they can come in all sorts
of different bombs and creams and sprays
they even have bath soaps where you can
sit in a tub with cannabis infused epsom
salts and poultices or muds and if you
think about it our endocannabinoid
system is found everywhere including the
skin we have nerve endings as evidenced
by horrible pain when we get something
as minimal as a paper cut which means we
have nerves there
therefore cb1 receptors and that once we
get that cut our immune system is
allowed to help us prevent infection and
promote healing so we have cb2 receptors
so we have these receptors that are
there to benefit using topicals
so i want to share with you some
interesting things that i found with
patients one is something there is CI pn
it's chemotherapy-induced peripheral
neuropathic pain over a million people
have been treated with tax awe which is
one of making or therapy agents that
creates this peripheral neuropathy there
is no fda-approved treatment it's
extremely debilitating where people may
be alive after their chemotherapy but
they're left with horrific pain and I
want to share with you a case of a 68
year old woman who had ovarian cancer
treatment and at the time I saw her she
was unable to wear shoes because her
feet were so painful she was unable to
participate in her normal Affairs she
had three children who were all into
sports and she couldn't get to see any
of them because she couldn't walk she
was prescribed lyrica
antidepressant medicines anti-seizure
medicines and opiates she did poorly
with tremendous amount of side effects
with the other medications and she
didn't want to try opiates because she
was afraid of addiction so we started
her on a topical cream three times a day
and she was able to put on socks and
shoes and see her family or children at
all of its sporting events skin cancer
so this is a patient 74 year old
gentleman white actinic keratosis
it's a precancerous lesion he had it
surgically excised it grew back
they put topical 5fu or chemotherapy
agent on it it grew back and so he was
placed on a topical cream for six weeks
then two years later it still looks like
this and so I hope that today's
conversation was compelling where we can
see that there is not just an
intersection between food and cannabis
in health-promoting ways but actually a
direct connection between food and then
if needed cannabis is a reasonable
therapeutic options that can help
promote and benefit health and crime and
prevent chronic illnesses and now I'm
ready for any questions thank you thank
you dr. can lists put on a four minute
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask the question
drop down box located on the far left
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for let's get started our
first question is how do you begin the
dosing protocol so that's a really
difficult question because everybody
responds differently but because
cannabis is predominantly systemically
and is stored I start with what I call
the med in medicine minimal effective
dose and so when I trial all of my
patients with this low dose cannabis I
start really low so I ask that even
though one ml is 1.17 of total
cannabinoids I start out with a quarter
of an ml point two five that I would
administer haven't administer under
their tongue they hold it there for five
minutes and swallow and I do that for
about three days until I slowly advance
their dose and then we follow their
benchmarks their parameters how are they
feeling believe it or not in some
patients then you feel some psycho
activity with that some patients do not
and I want them to have an experience
where they're not feeling psycho
activity where they can go about their
daily affairs and be functional while
they're being treated great and the
second question is the strain matter so
more importantly then strain is what is
in this strain so I make sure that all
of my patients have medicine that's
tested and when you have medicine that's
tested you understand what the
cannabinoids are that are found in that
particular medicine what the terpenes
are in that medicine everybody responds
differently to different things so the
reason why strain what matter is because
if one thing didn't work something else
did but without those laboratory tests
it's sort of like shooting in the dark
and not having a scorecard no
standing what worked what did work and
then we move on from there then we have
time for one more question
and it says why are most physicians and
health care providers not discussing
nutrition that's a good question if it
is is that there are many many more
doctors out there that have an
understanding about the power of
nutrition as I described here today but
you're right there's a big disconnect
and that's because in medical schools
and pretty much all healthcare
professional schools not only is the
endocannabinoid system not taught but
really nutrition is not taught as well
but there are lots and lots of movies
and books and different information
channels that are available that are out
there that patients can start actually
teaching doctors and their healthcare
providers so that you can understand the
power of nutrition I would like to once
again thank dr. Kim list for her
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for an on-demand
viewing 3rd June of 2018 you will
receive an email from lobbyists letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye